مشاهدينا من القاهره الفنانه جواهر اهلا
وسهلا فيكي جواهر معنا وصباح الخير صباح
الخير نورتينا بصباح العربيه
الراويه والتمر صباحكم معطر بعطر عربي
فاخر سعيد انه النهارده انا معكم يعني يا
جواهر انا بدي استخدم كلمات اغنيه شهيره
عشان اسالك سؤال وصلتينا لنص البير وقطعتي
حبلك فينا من عام 2016 وين هالغيبه طيب
والله يعني هو طبعا كان غصبا عني يعني
اجت الربيع العربي وبعد كده دخلنا في
الموضوع كورونا وبعد كده والدتي توفت ففي
اسباب كتيره جدا خلتني بعد شويه انما
دلوقتي بشكل الله يرحمها انما دلوقتي بشكل
مكثف انا في الريف العربي بعمل حفلات صفيه
يومي حفلات نهاريه حتى بعد شويه انا هطلع
على الاستاد ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
بالموفقيه طيب جواهر اليوم برايك يعني قبل
شوي كنا نتكلم عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
خلينا نقول ايش قد اليوم وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تدعم وصول الفنان الى جماهير
الى قاعده واسعه من الجماهير خصوصا انك في
لقاء سابق قلتي انه المشكله اليوم مع
المنتجين ومع الانتاج يتم تسريب مقاطع او
كليبات
اغاني او لاعمال بس بنفس الوقت هو سلاح ذو
حدين يمكن
اكيد طبعا يعني
وجود الانتاج بقى قليل جدا
نسبه لقرصنه النت فالاغنيه ممكن تنزل مثلا
ما فيش خمس دقايق تلاقي على النت فده
بيبقى خراب بيوت زي ما انا قلت قبل كده
مستعجل للمنتج انما بالنسبه للمطربين
بتبقى دي حاجه كويسه جدا طيب جواهر لديك
كثير من الشركات بدون قطعي كلامك الشركات
العربيه بقى تشبه منعدمه ما عدا شركه
روتانا وكم شركه طبعا لهم التحيه كويس
انهم لا زالوا موجودين لان هم اقوياء
بصراحه يعني هو الحقيقه يمكن علمنا العربي
بحاجه لبعض التنظيمات القانونيه فيما
يتعلق بحقوق النشر والملكيه الفكريه ولكن
جواهر غير غير اوروبا اكيد غير اوروبا
امريكا بالفعل طيب جواهر انت يعني عده
اغاني انت غنيتيها ومن زمن كسرت الدنيا زي
ما بيقولوا في عندك حماده
على الكورنيش اسمريكا
سر برايك بنجاح هذه الاغاني بشكل كبير
وعلى مستوى العالم العربي هل هي الاغنيه
نفسها ام التوقيت اللي يعني انتشرت فيها
او تم اصدارها هذه الاغاني فيها
انا عايزه اقول لك الاغاني بتاعتي اللي
انت ذكرتيها دي لما لما انا انتشرت
وعملتها ما كانش في سوشيال ميديا خالص
يعني مثلا كان في قناه مثلا عربيه مثلا
قناه دبي مثلا الفضائيه المصريه يعني ما
كانش في قنوات فضائيه كثيره مكان
ياسر ام بي سي طبعا اساسي ما كناش يعني
دخلنا على موضوع السوشيال ميديا زي دلوقتي
فكونك تنتشر في الوقت ده والاغاني تبقى
توب وكانت نمبر وان في كل الوطن العربي
فده كان فضل وعدل من عند ربنا انما
بالنسبه للنجاحات في اغنيه اسمها يا دنيا
واخداني نجحت جدا
وفي اغنيه اتعملت لعيد ميلاد وفي اغنيه
اسمها معطلتش
دي برضو لسه منزلاها قريب دي برضه نجحت
جدا لا في رجوع بشكل قوي جدا
من الاغاني الجديده اللي موجوده عندك من
الاغاني الجديده اذا في شيء نقدر نسمعه
اكيد
اوكي وطبعا انا بشكر اداره
الريف العربي لاتاحه الفرصه انه بقى
متواجده بشكل يومي في الحفلات الصيفيه
عندهم وشكرا لكم طبعا والنطه الخلفيه
الكاميرا ولاداره البرنامج فغني لك بصي
اغنيه بحبها جدا وعايزه اقول لك في دبي
مكسره الدنيا اغنيه لو جابولي الامريكان
وبعد كده اغني لك الجديد ايه رايك يلا
انا لو جابولي الامريكان الانجليزي
والياباني وكنوز الدنيا عشان اقول له لا
لا يا حبيبي لا لا مش هو دلع حس بيه ولا
قلبي بيجري عليه لو يعمل عشان ايه هاقول
له لا لا يا حبيبي لا لا والله ما احب
غيره غير وحدي تاني ولا قلبي يكون اسير
غيره حد تاني غير بس غير بس العربي الاسمر
اني حبيبتي يا بخته اذا هيك العربي
الاسمراني طيب يا جواهر اكيد يا بخته اكيد
اذا بتغني له اغنيه
جواهر انت
لجقتي الى مصر وبداتي مشوارك الفني من
هناك ويعني الحقيقه هي مصر هي وجهه من
يريد ان يدخل هذا العالم عالم الفن من
اوسع ابوابه بالعالم العربي
حقيقه هي جواز مرور لكل فنان لكل مبدع
يعني بصراحه بالفعل ولكن الان المشهد الان
المشهد الفني في السودان كيف بتقيميه وهل
هناك فرص لفنانين صاعدين ومواهب عن جد
حقيقيه تخرج من السودان انها تنطلق من
السودان دون اللجوء لمصر او اي دول اخرى
للانطلاق
لان عايزه اقول لك حاجه يعني بصي طالما
فتحنا موضوع السودان اولا انا طبعا بطرحهم
لكل الشهداء في السودان وربنا يشفي الجرحى
واتمنى انه يا رب الشمل يتلموا الجرح يطيب
باسرع وقت لانه اللي بيحصل في السودان
بصراحه
فوق فوق الخيال يعني زي ما بيقولوا كده
فوق الخيال السودان ما بتشبهش الحرب
بصراحه مش شبه الحرب السودان خالص يعني
فربنا يا رب يتولانا برحمته ان شاء الله
اما بخصوص الفن السوداني الفن السوداني
موجود لانه السودانيين بيحبوا النوعيه
الغنائيه بتاعتهم يعني زي السمك لو طلع من
البحر ما يقدرش يتنفس بس انت انت قدرتي
تحققي الجماهيريه كبيره خارج السودان
انا الحمد لله نجحت في الوطن العربي ونجحت
في اوروبا يعني خدت جوائز كبيره جدا في
مهرجانات دوليه في اوروبا يعني الحمد لله
يعني لو اتكلمنا عن الجواز بتاعتي ما بين
ميه ما بين 200 250
الحمد لله يعني على مدار مشواري اللي
نفعني لانه انا من ابنوبي وامي سودانيه
يعني اب مصري وامي سودانيه ممكن ده اللي
الخليط ده هو اللي خلاني مثلا انجح في مصر
بشكل اكبر
لانه انا بحب الغناء الشرقيه هو دمج ما
بين النوب الصعيدي السوداني
جميل جميل طيب بالنسبه اذا اذا عندك مشروع
دودته مثلا من تختارين من الفنان من
الفنانين اللي عمل دويتو معهم
والله بصي هو كله مدى الواحد احلامه
بتتطور بس انا نفسي بصراحه اغني اغنيه
خليجيه
طيب جواهر انا لسه من من بجد حقيقه يعني
من كم يوم انا لسه كنت بقول للاداره عندي
المكتب المكتب
الاداره عندي بقول لهم انا شوفوا لي حد
انا نفسي اعمل اغنيه خليجيه بتبقى ديومه
بينه وبينه اتكسر الدنيا ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله طيب احنا حابين نكسر
صباح العربيه الان دي اغنيه جديده تغني
لنا اياها من اختيارك يعني انا بحب حماده
مثلا بس الخيار لالك ست جواهر
طب والله لاغني لك حماده عشان ما تزعليش
طالما انت بتحبي حماده اغنيلك
حبيبتي تسلمي لي
والله
بتموتي يا حماده انا بعدك انت اموت يا
حماده ده انا قلبي في نار والهوى غدار
وبموت
حماده حماده انت اعز الناس حماده قلبي
قفلته خلاص
انت اللي قريب مني ساكن في العين والنني
والله اما بتبعد عني ما بحس باي سعاده انا
والله بحبك موت يا حماده يا حماده الله
الله برضو محظوظ حماده
ههه الله يخليك يا حبيبتي تسلميلي ايه ده
الفنانه جواهر كانت معنا شكرا جزيلا
لتواجدك معنا اليوم وبالمزيد من الموفقيه
يا رب شكرا شكرا لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات